And and you know I think we dealt with
this before uh Sam and this is a
question that usually is misinterpreted
by certain group and and he's referring
to one of them right now a modalist for
instance that will insist or at least
one that's been aostle sometimes will
insist that the baptism in Jesus's name
is a proof of what they believe in
technically speaking the assumption is
for those who don't know that throughout
the book of acts the apostles are found
to command people to be baptized into
the name of Jesus. Jesus Christ. And let
me give you one as an example. Acts
2:38. In Acts 2:37, when the Jews were
cut at the heart, they said to the
apostles headed by Peter, "Men, what
shall we do?" Acts 2:38, here's the
answer. "Repent and be baptized, every
one of you into the name of Jesus Christ
for the forgiveness of sins, and you
shall receive the gift of the Holy
Spirit." See, they're baptized into the
name of Jesus Christ. And yet here in
Matthew 28:19, our Lord Jesus Christ
said, "Go make disciples of all nations,
baptizing them into the name singular of
the father and the son of the holy
spirit." So the assumption is the name
of the father and the son holy spirit is
Jesus because people got baptized in the
name of Jesus. So if they got baptized
in the name of Jesus, but you're
supposed to baptize in the name of the
father and holy spirit, that means the
father's name is Jesus, the son's name
is Jesus, the holy spirit's name is
Jesus. Okay, here's my challenge to
these modalist heretics. And they are
heretics and they don't worship the same
god. They worship a false god. I
challenge any one of them to show me
that this is the formula, the words that
the apostles uttered when they immersed
an individual into the waters of
baptism. Show me a single place in the
New Testament where when Peter immersed
someone, he goes and I I baptize you in
the name of Jesus Christ. This is not a
baptismal formula in the book of Acts.
What does it mean then when it says be
baptized into the name of Jesus Christ?
It
means be baptized for the sake of Christ
because of Christ because Christ
commands you to do so. In other words,
it's not a
formula. It is actually indicating why
someone should get baptized. You should
get baptized for the sake of Christ.
because of Christ because Christ
commands you to do so in the name of me
means because of the authority of Jesus
Christ who authorizes us to bind you to
get baptized for his sake. It's not a
formula. It's simply indicating that we
command you to get baptized because
Christ gives us the authority and
authorizes us to command you to get
baptized for his sake on his behalf if
you believe in him and submit to him.
That's all it's saying.
I don't know if that's clear, but I want
to make sure people got it. If not, ask
me to clarify. It's not a formula. It's
like when Paul says in Acts 16:16
to8, I command you in the name of Jesus
Christ to come out of her. when he cast
out that evil spirit in the name of
Jesus Christ. That's not a formula, but
it's simply indicating by the power of
Jesus Christ, by the authority of Jesus
Christ, you must leave because you evil
spirit are under the authority of
Christ. Christ is Lord over you and he
controls you and owns you and you have
no choice but to submit to the one who
creates you and will judge you. and he's
given me authority to demand that you
leave for his sake by his authority who
will call you into judgment and condemn
you on the last day. You see, so I want
everyone to understand what in the name
of into the name of means. So that's
what it means in book of acts. We
command you for the sake of Christ on
behalf of Christ by the authority that
Christ gives us who authorize us to bind
you to these commands for his sake on
his behalf if you believe in him. That's
all it means. What about Matthew 28:19?
Matthew 28:19 is highlighting the fact
that when you get baptized, you're doing
so as a sign that you are coming under
the
authority, the sovereignty, the headship
of the father and the son, holy spirit.
Let me expound on that a little bit. The
right of
baptism is an act. It's a religious
right, meaning ritual done to honor the
deity that you surrender to. Water
baptism is what we call a right ri I t a
ritual
a practice that the person does does as
a sign and demonstration that he or she
is coming under the authority submitting
to the authority of the deity for whose
sake the act is being performed.
So this act of baptism is being
performed for the sake of the father and
the son and the holy spirit as a sign
that that person willfully comes under
the authority and sovereignty of the
father's holy spirit indicate that he
acknowledges that the father son holy
spirit own him or her and have every
right to tell that person how to live
what to do and how to do it and what not
to do. In other words, it's an
indication that we believers come under
the authority and submit to the power
and authority of the father and the son
and the holy spirit equally because
father, son, holy spirit, all three of
them
equally have ownership over us, own us,
possess us and are sovereign over our
lives. That's what that act means.